didn't know what was going on I was
calling out to God to forgive me for my
sins because I was 100 certain I was
going to hit the floor and die the only
thing I could think about was me kids
having no father growing up and that was
it nothing else really mattered my
alcohol is an extraordinarily pernicious
drug and if you're inclined towards it
you can be inclined towards it because
you're sensitive to its anxiety reducing
Properties or you can be sensitive to it
because it enhances social communication
or because it produces a psychomotor
high like cocaine or all of those at
once and if you're particularly
predisposed to alcoholism you can
experience all three at once having a
lot of time at home I think a lot of
people had this same sort of thing
alcohol it was just really it was
getting earlier and earlier yes easier
and easier to go to